[Music]
before he disappeared Brian destroyed
pictures of himself his mother was Anna
Rodriguez has just a few left this one
taken a month before her son vanished
shows the young man holding his niece in
his arms he disappeared in the middle of
the night I don't know why no goodbyes
nothing and for six months I haven't
heard from him it makes me so sad to
lose my son like this my only son who I
love so much Brian is now thought to be
fighting in Syria for the militant
al-nusra front
he's one of some 80 Belgians who've
joined the Islamist group like more
moderate Syrian rebel groups al-nusra
wants to topple the Assad regime
hundreds of young Muslims from Europe
have followed its call
on this internet video Brian is the
youth who seems uncertain about where to
put his gun before prayers start
his mother showed us where it all
started in an apartment block in the
south of Antwerp this is where Brian
grew up as a Catholic his childhood
revolved around school and soccer some
of the neighbors in the building will
radical Muslims this is where my life's
misfortune began with that gang of
bastards who live here I hate those
people really if I could I would grab
them with my hands and throw them down
here as simple as that parking the
beneath the track my my parents so
superstar the people of zona is so angry
at our from the Salafist group
sharia4belgium in April it was raided by
the police its spokesman Fuad Becca SEM
also known as Abu Ammar Amma is now in
jail
two years ago Brian came under the
group's influence
hosana says she still doesn't know why
this sharia4belgium the sharia4belgium
people would park here and behind there
and talk to the boys here at Glenn Platz
and over there a youtube video shows
four had baked a sim at the edge of the
basketball court he spends an hour
talking to the men who listened with
interest the short head youth sitting
next to him is Brian a Muslim must be a
practicing Muslim not a theoretical
Muslim we study in practice and that is
what we need now we need a generation of
soldiers
the Syria fighters are a problem for the
Muslim community in Belgium Muslims feel
they're being victimized because of a
small radical minority in fact Muslim
communities first demanded action
against sharia4belgium they were sick of
seeing youths being indoctrinated I
believe those young men have no idea
what damage they're doing to Islam and
Muslims here who are the first victims
they are inciting hatred against Muslims
and they're making people afraid of
Islam and that's very bad for us and is
making our lives more difficult in March
the Belgian government set up a special
task force bringing ministries and
intelligence services together to tackle
the problem of belgian fighters in syria
how to stop the proselytizing how to
prevent young people from going to syria
and how to deal with ideologically
committed militarized young men
returning from the war questions the
interior minister was reluctant to
elaborate on it's a multi-dimensional
problem it's about terrorism and about
public order but it's also about runaway
miners who have been influenced and who
have to be protected and brought home
local antwerp politician Hisham Elms
heir knows many of the affected families
he's tried to take steps against
sharia4belgium as deceiver became law
Contador back in 2007 I wrote a paper
with 21 suggestions for what to do about
the radicalization of youngsters one of
them was that we should train our own
Imams but so far we don't have any such
training program lady monotony
Ozona rodrigues just wants her son back
she had already moved her family out of
antwerp away from the islamists and she
still hopes her son will find his way
back again to those banaz this manga
theory he's a it's been six months since
he's been away and I still can't believe
it sometimes when I go into the kitchen
I have the impression that he's there or
is about to arrive any moment
I hardly leave the house I'm scared that
he'll come home and I won't be there and
he could be in your thirst the last she
heard from Brian was a message on
Facebook in April in it he said he'd
contact his family
only if they converted to Islam
[Music]